Welcome to this lesson on data types and operators.
This is a very important lesson because it's where you'll learn about
the building blocks of Python datatypes and operators.
Students tend to learn how to program at different rates.
Take your time understanding each of the concepts that
follow and getting practice with activities in this lesson.
Having a firm grasp on these building blocks will provide a strong foundation
for future lessons and essential skills to continue programming beyond this course.
Throughout this course, we'll go through code examples using these boxes.
This first box represents the Code Editor which is where we will input our Python code,
and the second box represents
the output window which is where our results will be displayed.
You can follow along with the video examples in
the classroom by typing in the code editor below each video.
Click the Test Run button to run your code and view the results in the output window.
You'll be seeing this print function pretty often.
It helps us see what's going on in our code.
For example, let's say you wanted to compute three plus five.
If we run this line of code,
Python would still add three and five but we wouldn't see
the result because we didn't tell Python to do anything with it.
Print is a useful built-in function in Python that we can use to display our results.
All we have to do is type in Print followed by
parentheses around whatever we want printed.
You will be using Print often as you get to know the building blocks of Python,
its data types and operators.